hello everyone and welcome to a game
that really needs to be shown but still
wasn't shown on this channel while i was
having the stream
uh on friday uh during the friday arena
someone asked in the chat have i
ever covered uh anand versus laurier and
i was like uh
yeah i'm pretty sure i have but then i
checked and it turns out i haven't
uh so that's why i'm showing it now now
this is a this is a true masterpiece
it's a
one of uh i i think anand's definitely
one of one of the greatest games on par
with
that aaron vs anand in the 2013 tata
still
masters uh the the game for the aegis if
you haven't seen it
do check it out i will also put a link
to that game in the description below
uh first thing you will see uh but it
was played in 1997
it was the 30th annual billy
international uh chess festival and it
was a six player
uh double round rob and featured some of
the the very strong grand masters like
anand laudier uh anatoly karp of boris
great fund
uh and um well it's just uh
a scandinavian master class well sort of
an anti-scandinavian master class but
uh without spoiling too much let's just
check it out
it's it's just an amazing game uh so
anand with the white pieces
opens with e4 with d5 by laurier
uh it's the scandinavian defense of
course e captures queen captures and
knight to c3 and here
you have some options you can go back
with queen d8 you can go queen to d6
which is now very popular
uh queen to a5 or even queen to e6 check
if you want to you know joke around or
if it's a blizz game or not a very
important game but
magnus has been known to play both queen
d6 and queen to e6 in some
less important games but here we have
queen to a5 which was the norm in those
days
uh we have d for by island and now
knight to f6 we have knight to f3 and
c6 so this is all very standard making
the an escape route for the queen if
needed
we have bishop to c4 anand continues
developing and now bishop to f5 and this
is uh
even uh by today's standards the
absolute
mainist of the main line uh and here
bishop to d2 is
the most common move today but here anan
goes knight to e5 already threatening uh
captures on f7 so black needs to defend
this either by bishop g6 which is odd
because you kind of shifted the
tension in favor of white white will
always be the one who is able to capture
so e6 makes more sense which laurier
goes for we have
g 4 by anand uh forcing the bishop to
move back
bishop to g6 and now h4 with the idea of
just h5
and here knight b to d7 stopping h5
as now there's a a lot of pressure on
the knight here if you try h5 here
joel can just capture capture and
captures with check and later after
white blocks this you can simply move
the bishop bishop to e4 and black is
very happy grabbing that pawn
so instead after knight bd7 with knight
captures on d7 by anand
uh you could also capture on g6 but
again black would be very happy here he
gets the semi-open file for his rook he
will castle queen side
and not much for for what has happened
here uh so instead after this knight b
to d7 anand captures on d7
uh we have knight captures on d7 and
only now h5
we have bishop to e4 attacking the rook
and now
uh f3 is a possibility here castles is a
possibility here but anand goes for this
very nice rook lift
rook to h3 and now uh there is
actually a pretty big threat here and
black needs to be very careful for
example if you just continue playing
like nothing is
actually happening uh for example you
castle true white still cannot
capture the bishop because the the
knight is pinned however
bishop to d2 and all of a sudden what
are you going to do with your bishop
your bishop is trapped
uh you no longer have the escape square
d5 because white just captures it
because the the knight will be defended
there and you will have opened up
an attack towards black's queen so here
you'd have to go bishop g2 rook g3
attacked the
bishop uh bishop to h1 and now rook to
g1
and the bishop is trapped and if black
wants to
at least somehow uh not lose any
material he will have to open up his
king side b5
you're gonna go bishop b3 b4 attack the
knight and only now uh will you capture
the bishop
captures captures and captures and we
get this position where white is uh up
upon he has the bishop pair black's
position is completely busted
and the white will have white should be
able to win this game
so uh it's uh it's a really tough
position after this rook to h3 for black
and black really needs to decide how he
will tackle this so
first uh lodi goes for bishop to g2 he
attacks on under rook we have
rook to e3 and only now knight to b6 you
could now shift the bishop to d5 it's
possible
but he wants to get the knight over to
the d5 to put more pressure on the
on the knight and on the rook on e3 so
knight to b6
attacking the bishop bishop d3 and now
knight the knights the d5 attacking
both the knight and the rook uh and well
now there's just a double attack on the
night
the rook is under attack so it's not an
easy uh
thing for white to figure out what to
play here uh but uh you know feel free
to pause the video and try to find what
anand played here is just a wonderful
move so
you know while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
spotting that you can actually trap the
dark the light square bishop
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show anand played f3 here
and now uh it's it looks crazy because
the rook is hanging you can capture the
knight but none of this
actually works for black because if
knight captures rook and this was played
in one game and white just won a very
nice game
uh bishop captures and now you're still
gonna lose this uh
bishop just king f2 and there is no way
for this bishop to escape you're just
gonna grab two pieces for the
uh for the rook uh so even if a line
like bishop to a3 is played which is the
best uh for black
uh with the idea that if captures then
captures you're just going to play
bishop c1
and you will claim your bishop whatever
you play bishop h3 king f2 even if you
try f5 to open up the position just king
g3
captures captures and now the bishop is
finally captured you will have to give
it up for
for for a pawn and now white will just
be very happy he will play bishop g5
bring the rook into the game and even
though his king is somewhat opened
ah doesn't really matter because you're
you're up material
uh so this is what happens after this uh
f3
move if uh joel goes for knight captures
here there's also the possibility of
capturing the knight and c3 and even
this was played
twice uh but in both in both instance
instances
uh white just one because after captures
and captures with
check just bishop d2 the rook is nicely
protected
queen captures on b4 and now you play
king f2 you don't really
mind bishop will have to capture you
cannot capture with the queen because of
just queen captures rook but then king
captures and you're again very happy you
have two rooks you have the bishop
pair and well even though black has
three pieces for uh three pawns for a
piece it it will not be enough
uh but uh you know it can be played
definitely can be played
so knight captures on c3 is an option
but in practice uh
black never really got anything from it
so here after f3
we have bishop to b4 by joel and it is
as of
15 that this position has never been
reached again
so what can anand do here anand just
says okay i don't mind the triple attack
here i'm just going to continue doing my
thing
king f2 i attacked the bishop and here
joel find uh found a very interesting
line
bishop captures on c3 b captures and now
uh not knight captures if knight
captures queen e1 just wins because
the knight cannot move bishop d2 is
coming and that's just game
so queen captures on c3 and now rook to
b1 the rook is under attack so you have
to move it and now queen captures on d4
and now there's a double attack on the
rook so if you capture the bishop now
you're gonna win the rook and the bishop
so uh very very nicely played by
joel uh and here the problem is uh
you can't really do this if you go for
it then just captures captures and
captures you could go for b7 but black
just castles here
and uh well you're up the exchange and
black will have a winning game
so here after queen captures on d4 we
have rook captures on b7 by anand and
here anand says i don't mind if you
capture here because
you're not castling your king is staying
in the center of the board
point is that if castle is just the
bishop captures an h7
and the queen the queen is lost after
you capture this queen captures on d4
and white wins so here instead uh after
this rook captures on b7 uh
laurier played uh rook to d7 now after
the knight moves the
queen will be defended and also there's
a lot more pressure on white's queen
here on the d
file uh but here anand has uh such a
such a brilliancy that uh well i i must
urge you to pause the video and
try and find it while i again give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations not only if you
spotted the move but also if you
understood why the move is played and
for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's h6 and
h6 is such a
such a deep move that uh well once you
see it
you you finally believe it but uh you
know playing
playing it actually in an over the board
game is just remarkable uh point is
what anand wants to do here he wants to
open up this diagonal for his light
square bishop because the light square
bishop has
access to this diagonal but anand also
needs to make sure he has access to this
diagonal which
we're going to show why so here what can
you play here
well you could just ignore it and now
finally capture the rook because now
your queen is defended there is no
tricky business here
for example bishop captures queen e5
again keeping an eye on the bishop so if
king captures you can always capture
here
but now comes h captures on g7 rook g8
and
queen to c1 defending the bishop and
you're you're going after the light
square bishop this is what this game
about this entire game is
is about this light square bishop being
trapped here and it's
one of well the main reason why all the
tactics work in anand's favor
and here the bishop is trapped you're
gonna have to go after this but now bla
white even doesn't have to capture first
he can first just stray down into an in
game here anand
threatens checkmate and uh there's no
good way to defend this you're gonna
have to trade here and after captures
captures you're just gonna capture the
bishop
and you're gonna enjoy this end game a
winning endgame where you have two
bishops so a bishop pair for for black's
rook
uh completely winning for white so here
after h6
uh joel said all right i see you're
planning some
devious stuff here i'm just gonna
capture this pawn and i'm gonna
play knight captures on e3 next or
depending on what you play
but now comes a move that well you had
to see
if you found h6 but just in case you
didn't for the last time
pause the video and find the move you
know while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
well definitely one of the one of the
greatest moves ever played
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop the g6
that's right that's that's what it's all
about bishop to g6
and white wins and now there are so many
so many threats so many possibilities
here so firstly anand's queen is now
uh hanging so if joel wants joe can just
pick up on un's queen but the problem is
after queen captures queen
now not bishop captures here this looks
very interesting but then the king just
moves and after
the bishop delivers check the knight can
block the bishop's check
so there's an even stronger forced
mating for rook
captures on e6 check and now you don't
really have a lot of options
if king f8 now uh the opening of this
diagonal makes sense and this is why
anand had to play h6
bishop captures on h6 with check king g8
and now
bishop captures on f7 is checkmate so
this is the
the good stuff and uh if rook captures
an e7 after this
on e6 uh joel just blocks with knight to
e7
it doesn't really help you just capture
it here and it's the the exact same
checkmate captures king the g8 and
bishop captures on f7
a very nice double bishop check
checkmate
so after this bishop to g6 joel of
course saw okay it's not possible to
capture the queen
let's just uh play something but there
there is nothing to play
so here joel tried knight to e7 now okay
blocking rook captures and e6 because it
no longer comes with
check but now anand finds the the
absolute
the absolute simplest way of how to win
the game now that all of the tactics
have worked for him uh the game uh once
again
turns around uh to this uh traps light
square bishop here on g2 and anand plays
the absolute simplest queen captures on
d4
rook captures and now combining
everything
rook to d3 saying you either capture and
my bishop gets out of harm's way
or if you move the rook let's say rook
c4 then just rugby to check and
everything falls apart because
you you no longer have the option of
moving the king so you have to give up
the knight
after capture so you're going to have to
give up the the rook and everything just
falls apart
rook captures on c2 you're going to
block this and after captures you're
finally going to capture this bishop on
g2 and you are up
a whole bishop and a rook so here after
rook to d3
joel said all right uh well if i capture
dangerous bishop capture so i will not
i will not be capturing this bishop
either way so i'm going to play rook to
d8
but now nothing just works because rook
captures on the eight we have king
captures and now
everything wins here bishop captures
wins rook checks wins uh bishop back to
d3 wins
and it was in this position that uh joel
lottie resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
and once again we return to the trap the
bishop on g2
uh who is trapped and there is no way
for him to escape he will have to give
up the bishop and after king captures
uh anand will just be up a full piece in
a completely winning
endgame so yeah uh definitely a great
one uh so thank you for for recommending
uh
that i show it uh there are you know uh
games as epic as this one that i still
haven't shown but you know
i've only been doing this for a few
years we're going to go through them all
at some point
so yeah a great game against joel odier
he was born in canada but he's a french
grandmaster he was a two times french
champion i think in
2004 in 2006 and all in all a very
strong grandmaster
and uh cheating a game like this against
uh such strong player
i mean h6 followed by bishop to g6 and
absolute
masterpiece and uh you know again
against the scandinavian so no
no wonder you know scandinavian never
never got its uh
fair share of glory but we are we are
still waiting to see the
the scandinavian masterpiece and
regarding the standings of the
tournament even though and
uh lost one uh game uh that was a bit of
a
uh you know a surprise to mill of uh he
was still able to win the tournament
half a point uh ahead of anatoly karpov
and clinch first place uh first place in
this
uh 30th edition of the beale
international chess festival so anand
karp of gail van lordier
milo and pelletier uh so these were the
the final standings uh so yeah that's
the game
i do hope you enjoyed it like i said if
you haven't uh watched uh aaron vs anand
from the 2013 tata steel chess masters
do check it out it will be the first
link in the description below
uh really a mind-blowing game also so do
check it out
i would like to thank santa sharp frank
combs gunner lipka
kevin cole and david kimura for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your sunday
and i do hope this game improved it at
least a little bit
see you soon